♪ ♪
>> Sean: THEY LEFT ATTEMPT TO
SHUT DOWN AND DEMONIZE
CONSERVATIVES IS RAMPING UP.
THIS TIME THEY ARE ATTACKING
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATOR CANDACE OWENS FOR
TAKING ON BLACK LIVES MATTER
PROTESTERS DURING AN EVENT AT
UCLA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING DOWN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY, THERE IS AN
IDEOLOGICAL CIVIL WAR HAPPENING.
BLACK PEOPLE FOCUSED ON THE PAST
AND SHOUTING ABOUT SLAVERY AND
PEOPLE FOCUSED ON THE FUTURE.
THE VICTIM MENTALITY IS NOT
COOL.
I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE LIKE
BEING OPPRESSED.
I LOVE OPPRESSION.
FOREIGN YEARS OF SLAVERY.
JAMES CROWE, NONE OF YOU LIVE
THROUGH IT.
IT'S EMBARRASSING THAT YOU
UTILIZE THEIR HISTORY.
UTILIZE THEIR HISTORY AND COME
IN HERE WITH MORE EMOTION THAN
THEY WERE LIVING THROUGH IT.
MORE EMOTION THAN THEY EVER HAVE
AND THEY WERE LIVING THROUGH IT.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
YOU ARE NOT LIVING THROUGH
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE OVERLY PRIVILEGED
AMERICANS.
>> Sean: ON SATURDAY
KANYE WEST PRAISED ALWAYS
WRITING "I LOVE THE WAY CANDACE
OWENS THINKS, BUT NOT EVERYONE
IS A FAN WITH COMPLEMENTS.
LOOK AT WHAT TOM ARNOLD WENT A
SEXIST, BRUTAL, VICIOUS, HATEFUL
RACIST TIRADE.
HERE ARE SOME OF IT.
ASIDE FROM BEING AN INSANE
ALT-RIGHT --
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS ANYMORE.
CANDACE JOINS US.
YOU ARE A TOTAL STAR.
I WATCH THAT TAPE.
I AM SO IMPRESSED AND SO HAPPY
FOR YOU THAT YOU HAVE THIS GIFT.
BUT I AM SO SAD FOR YOU ALSO
THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE ON THOSE
VICIOUS ATTACKS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
COMPLIMENT.
IT MEANS A LOT COMING FROM YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU, DO NOT BE SAD
FOR ME.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED
AND IT'S EXACTLY WHAT I INTENDED
BECAUSE I KNEW EXACTLY WHAT I
WAS GOING UP AGAINST.